This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's a well-known literary technique called check-offs gun, named after the Russian playwright. Basically, if a gun appears in the first act, it better be fired in the following act. There are no unnecessary details. You see a gun, that gun gets used to shoot someone. I have a corollary principle of my own invention and it relates to movies where there is a scene at a construction site, and it is this. If on the screen you see an ugly shaft of exposed rebar, somebody is getting impaled. There's something about rebar that fascinates me.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。文学界有一个著名的技巧叫契诃夫之枪，是以这位俄罗斯剧作家命名的。基本上，如果在第一幕中出现了一把枪，那么在接下来的幕中它就必须被发射。这里没有多余的细节。你看到了一把枪，那把枪就会用来射杀某人。我也有一个自己发明的推论原则，它与电影中在建筑工地发生的一幕有关，具体是这样的：如果在银幕上看到一根难看的暴露钢筋，就会有人被串起来。钢筋身上有一种东西让我着迷。
If nothing else because there are very few things that invoke a fear of being skewered. My pathological preoccupation with metal reinforcement bars dovetails nicely with a structure in San Francisco I've kind of become obsessed with a tiny bridge in Golden Gate Park. This is the Alfred Lake Bridge by Ernest Ransom. This is William Littman. He teaches architecture at the California College of the Arts, and he was the first person to
至少没有多少东西能唤起人们对被串烤的恐惧。我对金属增强筋的病态执着，与旧金山的一个结构完美契合，我开始对金门公园里的一座小桥着迷。这就是欧内斯特·兰森建造的阿尔伯特湖桥。这位是威廉·利特曼。他在加州艺术学院教授建筑学，他是第一个
tip me off to the importance of this humble little structure on the very eastern edge of the park. It's sort of the entrance to the park, from the hate side, from the kind of hippie slacker hate area right at the edge of the park, sort of leading into the children's playground. It's not a place that most people really want to linger. It is a spot for drug dealing and various illicit assignations. And that is Robert Corlin, author of Concrete Planet,
向我透露公园最东端这座朴素小结构重要性的人。这可以说是进入公园的入口，从海特那一侧，从公园边缘那个嬉皮士闲散的海特地区过来，可以说是通往儿童游乐场。这里并不是大多数人真正想要逗留的地方。这里是毒品交易和各种非法约会的场所。那是《混凝土星球》的作者罗伯特·科林，
giving us a lay of the land. We're in the Albert Lake Bridge, one of the earliest surviving reinforced concrete structures in the world. The bridge was constructed in 1889. It may be the least appealing sort of monument of architecture or civil engineering. On one side, it's cracked where the earth is sort of pressing through. It's covered in mold and lichen. Inside, it's this kind of odd surrealistic tunnel of stalactites that really kind of
为我们介绍这片土地。我们正身处阿尔伯特湖桥，它是世界上现存最早的钢筋混凝土结构之一。这座桥建于 1889 年。它可能是建筑或土木工程中最不具吸引力的纪念碑。在一侧，它已经开裂，泥土从缝隙中挤压出来。上面长满了霉菌和地衣。在内部，这是一个奇怪的、超现实的钟乳石隧道，真的很像
look like some sort of folk art, you know, impression of what the surface of Mars might look like. I think it looks like the inside of a giant colon. It's really unappealing to pass through it. It's not well kept up at all. Well, there's nothing remarkable about it. It is an arch. It's actually as much a pedestrian tunnel as a bridge. A pioneering structure in the shape of a dumpy and the collected little bridge. But that's really sad because it is one of the pioneering buildings in the story of reinforced concrete.
某种民间艺术，你知道的，对火星表面样貌的印象。我觉得它看起来像一个巨型结肠的内部。穿过它真的非常没有吸引力。它根本没有得到很好的维护。嗯，它没有什么特别之处。它是一个拱门。实际上，它既是一个行人隧道，也是一座桥。这是一个矮胖而聚集的小桥形状的开创性结构。但这真的很遗憾，因为它是钢筋混凝土发展史上具有开创性的建筑之一。
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. There are plenty of candidates for the most overlooked, most invisible part of the built world, but reinforce concrete has a good claim to being the most invisible of all. Because if it's made right, you never see the steel skeleton underneath all of a concrete structures that you work in, drive over, walk under.
谢谢你。谢谢你。谢谢你。谢谢你。在人工建造的世界中，最容易被忽视、最隐形的候选者有很多，但钢筋混凝土最有资格成为其中最隐形的一个。因为如果它建造得正确，你永远不会看到你工作、驾车碾过、脚下走过的所有混凝土结构下面藏着的钢铁骨架。
Reinforce concrete is concrete that is strengthened by the addition of initially iron and then later steel to give it tensile strength. The thing about concrete is it's great in compression, meaning it's with stands a lot of pressure in terms of weight, but it's not very good intention, meaning when you, sort of, spanning long distances it sort of can collapse.
钢筋混凝土是通过在其中最初加入铁、后来加入钢来增强的混凝土，从而赋予其抗拉强度。混凝土的特点是抗压能力极强，这意味着它在承受重量方面可以承受很大的压力，但它的抗拉能力不是很好，这意味着当你跨越长距离时，它可能会坍塌。
So if you see concrete going high in the air or spanning a long distance, there is metal inside that. And you have this unassuming vanguard of a bridge and its engineer Ernest Ransom to thank for that. Ernst Ransom's principal claim to fame is that he's the father of modern reinforced concrete. The experiments done with reinforcing concrete with iron, previous to Ernst Ransom, were just one off experiments,
因此，如果你看到混凝土高高升入空中或跨越长距离，里面一定有金属。你要感谢这个桥梁的不起眼先锋及其工程师欧内斯特·兰森。欧内斯特·兰森最主要的成就是他是现代钢筋混凝土之父。在欧内斯特·兰森之前，用铁加固混凝土的实验只是零星的实验，
a cottage in England, house in New York, and a robot in France. Ernst Ransom experimented with different forms of iron reinforcement until he hit upon what we now call rebar, which is short for reinforcement bar. And his technology was far beyond any of the others who were experimenting with reinforced concrete at the time. A lot of people in Europe and America are playing with putting in bars or
英国的一座小屋，纽约的一座房子，以及法国的一个机器人。欧内斯特·兰森尝试了各种形式的铁加固，直到他偶然发现了我们现在所说的钢筋（rebar，即 reinforcement bar 的缩写）。他的技术远远领先于当时其他所有尝试钢筋混凝土的人。当时欧洲和美国的许多人都在尝试在混凝土中放入钢筋或
metal into concrete at this time. There's many different techniques and everyone's experimenting. What ransom's sort of major innovation is is he takes sort of square bar that runs through it and he twists it slightly and that gives it an adhesive quality to the concrete itself and sort of stays together much better. Ransom said to come to this idea he found a twisted rubber band in his pocket one day and thought well that's what I'm going to do to this iron bar. I'm going to twist it so it just binds to the concrete better.
金属。有许多不同的技术，每个人都在试验。兰森的主要创新在于，他拿出了穿过其中的方钢并对其进行了轻微的扭曲，这赋予了它与混凝土本身的粘附性，并能更好地结合在一起。兰森说，为了想出这个主意，他有一天在口袋里发现了一个扭曲的橡皮筋，心想，好吧，这就是我要对这根铁条做的事情。我要把它扭曲，以便它能更好地与混凝土结合。
You can see a diagram of this twisted rebar in Ransom's 1884 patent. By the way, if you're anything like me, Google Patent Search is the best way to spend time in front of the computer. I can lose hours jumping from patent to patent. Anyway, this innovation of messing with the bar to help it bond with the surrounding concrete is still used to this day. We put defamation on the reinforcing bar so that the concrete will hold on to it. That scoring is probably why I find rebar so ugly and unsettling.
你可以在兰森 1884 年的专利中看到这种扭曲钢筋的图表。顺便说一句，如果你和我一样，谷歌专利搜索是在电脑前消磨时光的最佳方式。我会在从一个专利跳转到另一个专利的过程中迷失好几个小时。无论如何，这种通过摆弄钢筋来帮助它与周围混凝土结合的创新至今仍在使用。我们在钢筋上制造变形，以便混凝土能够抓住它。这种刻痕可能就是为什么我觉得钢筋如此丑陋和令人不安的原因。
That's Bob Risser right there. I'm Bob Risser. I'm President and CEO of the concrete reinforcing steel institute. I call this C-R-S-I to get the full scope of what reinforced concrete means to the built world. Well, without exaggerating the point, I would say that the significance of reinforced concrete is that modern society is not possible without it. Well as humble as the Albert Lake Bridge is, it is a direct precursor to the Ingalls Sky Scraper built just 15 years later in Cincinnati, Ohio, the
那就是鲍勃·里瑟。我是鲍勃·里瑟。我是混凝土钢筋协会的总裁兼首席执行官。我称之为 C-R-S-I，以全面了解钢筋混凝土对建筑世界的意义。嗯，毫不夸张地说，我认为钢筋混凝土的重要性在于，没有它，现代社会是不可能存在的。虽然阿尔伯特湖桥很简陋，但它是仅仅 15 年后在俄亥俄州辛辛那提建造的英格尔斯摩天大楼的直接前身，
world's first reinforced skyscraper. It also led to bridges, dams, freeways, streets of reinforced concrete. I mean, without reinforced concrete, you would only be able to build a series of unconnected asphalt roads. It's a very humble beginning, but it was from here in San Francisco that the reinforced concrete revolution took over the world. That's why we talk about it being the foundation of civilization. It's also a foundation of modern architecture. It made possible forms that were never possible before, like Frank Lloyd Wright's Guggenheim
世界上第一座钢筋摩天大楼。它还催生了桥梁、水坝、高速公路和钢筋混凝土街道。我的意思是，如果没有钢筋混凝土，你只能建造一系列互不相连的沥青道路。这是一个非常卑微的起点，但正是从这里的旧金山开始，钢筋混凝土革命席卷了全球。这就是为什么我们说它是文明的基础。它也是现代建筑的基础。它使以前从未可能实现的建筑形态成为可能，比如弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的古根海姆
Museum, and more recently, Genie Gang's Aqua Tower in Chicago. It's designed to mimic flowing water on the 80s on floors. There are no two floors that are the same. There's no two balcon floors that are the same. There's no two balconies that are the same. But the problem with reinforced concrete, especially if the rebar isn't covered with enough concrete and it's exposed to water and salt, is that the steel inside can rust. And as it rusts, it expands. They expand to almost fourfold its original diameter, destroying the concrete around it while the steel itself is being destroyed by the rust and corrosion.
博物馆，以及最近芝加哥的珍妮·甘的 Aqua 大厦。它的设计旨在模仿 80 多层楼上流动的流水。没有哪两层楼是完全相同的。没有哪两个阳台楼层是完全相同的。没有哪两个阳台是完全相同的。但钢筋混凝土的问题在于，特别是如果钢筋没有被足够的混凝土覆盖并且暴露在水和盐中，里面的钢材就会生锈。随着它生锈，它会膨胀。它们的体积会膨胀到接近原来直径的四倍，在钢材本身被铁锈和腐蚀破坏的同时，摧毁周围的混凝土。
And when that happens, which it will eventually, reinforce concrete doesn't last the 1000 years that Ernest Ransom and the early reinforce concrete proponents thought that it would. For many many years, the design life was about 50 years. The entire interstate system was built under the assumption of a 50-year design. These days, our organization and others are working with the federal government and state agencies to try to look at 75 and even 100-year designs. Modern reinforced concrete frames encased inside of a building superstructure with normal maintenance will last a lot, lot longer. So don't worry, the Burk-Elifa, the tallest hour in the world, and the tallest reinforced concrete structure is not coming down anytime soon.
当这种情况发生时（而且最终一定会发生），钢筋混凝土并不能像欧内斯特·兰森和早期钢筋混凝土倡导者所认为的那样持续一千年。很多很多年里，设计寿命约为 50 年。整个洲际公路系统都是在 50 年设计的假设下建造的。如今，我们组织和其他机构正与联邦政府和州机构合作，尝试将设计寿命延长至 75 年甚至 100 年。在正常维护下，包裹在建筑物上层建筑内的现代钢筋混凝土框架将使用更长、更长的时间。所以不用担心，世界上最高的塔、最高的钢筋混凝土结构哈利法塔短期内不会倒塌。
But the clock is ticking for most of the reinforced concrete infrastructure that was put up in the middle of the 20th century in the US. People have to realize that all this that they see around them will eventually have to be with a few exceptions, will have to be torn down and replaced because we built with steel reinforced concrete. And the cost of that, it will be trillions of dollars, a unbelievable amount of money. Seriously, the stuff that wasn't properly maintained is coming down. And as you can imagine, a lot of our infrastructure was not properly maintained.
但对于美国 20 世纪中期兴建的大部分钢筋混凝土基础设施来说，倒计时已经开始。人们必须意识到，他们周围看到的所有这一切最终都将不得不（除少数例外）被拆除并更换，因为我们建造时使用的是钢筋混凝土。而这笔费用将达到数万亿美元，是一笔令人难以置信的巨款。说真的，那些没有得到适当维护的东西正在倒塌。正如你可以想象的那样，我们的许多基础设施并没有得到适当维护。
Particularly with public agencies where very frankly, the method has been, and in some cases still is, you know, a reactionary policy rather than a well thought out maintenance routine. Even though Concrete has the illusion of permanence, it is not that way at all. You just build it and forget it. You have to account for going back and taking care of it like you would. Anything else? Ernest ran some left San Francisco soon after he completed the Alvar Lake Bridge. In his book, Re-Enforce Concrete Buildings published in 1912, which is not the most central lighting of text, but in it you can detect a tinge of bitterness in Ransom's words as he describes how his twisted rebar was, quote, laughed down by the technical society in California. He left for the east, thinking that his revolution
特别是对于公共机构而言，坦率地说，其方法一直是，在某些情况下仍然是，一种反应式的政策，而不是深思熟虑的维护常规。尽管混凝土给人一种永久的错觉，但它根本不是这样的。你不能建好之后就置之不理。你必须像对待其他任何东西一样，考虑到回头去照顾它。欧内斯特·兰森在完成阿尔伯特湖桥后不久便离开了旧金山。在他于 1912 年出版的《钢筋混凝土建筑》一书中，这并不是最核心的文本，但你可以在其中察觉到兰森字里行间透出的一丝苦涩，他描述了他的扭曲钢筋是如何“被加利福尼亚的技术界嘲笑”的。他前往东部，认为他的
of reinforced concrete would have a better chance out there. He left thinking that no one here would fully appreciate his Albert Lake Bridge, that no one here would appreciate this literal bridge to the modern world. And looking at it today, I'm sad to say, that he was right. 99% invisible is Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars, but this week, oh my goodness, we have amazing photographs of the Alpha Lake Bridge as photographed by Eddie Joaquim, he just makes the ugliness and creepiness of that place look beautiful and stunning.
钢筋混凝土革命在那里会有更好的机会。他离开时认为，这里没有人会真正欣赏他的阿尔伯特湖桥，这里没有人会欣赏这座通往现代世界的字面意义上的桥梁。今天回过头来看，我很遗憾地说，他是对的。“99%隐形”节目的制作人员有萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 本地公共广播电台 KALW 以及旧金山美国建筑师学会的项目。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并点赞这个节目。我的推特账号是 Roman Mars，但本周，哦天哪，我们有埃迪·若金拍摄的阿尔伯特湖桥的精彩照片，他只是让那个地方的丑陋和诡异看起来美丽而惊艳。
You have to check them out. They're at 99%invisible.org. Video Topeon. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你必须去看看它们。它们的网址是 99%invisible.org。视频剪辑来自 PRX。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。